sie bekommen einen neuen blog heutiger
planung meine damen und herren wir sind
immer noch an der nordsee erstmal
deswegen gehen wir heute natürlich
erstmal an den strand allerdings ist das
nicht das einzige was heute abgeben wird
sondern wir haben gestern abend leute
kennengelernt die einen einen golden
retriever einem sechs monate alten
golden retriever wir uns bisher mit
denen angst sein denn auch mit dem hund
und dann haben sie uns gesagt hey wenn
ihr den runter haben wollt könnt ihr
heute gern wald von 18 bis 19 uhr mit
dem spazieren geht ja wohl wieder
vermischt und dann geholt werden ja
letztens schon mal den hund von den
nachbarn und sie mit denen gassi
gegangen
das war ich auch ganz neues und da bin
ich ja weg ich habe immer noch so einen
krassen sonnenbrand alter ich sehe aus
wie eine tomate frühstück der
mitmenschen nicht gesenkt ziemlich
abstoßend geschmeckt u
ich bin auf dem klo
wir gehen zum strand oder im schnellen
was ich wie soll ich bescheid weiß ich
aus ihrem kind beim wandertag liebe
wandertage 30 euro spaß ich wünsche euch
einen schönen tag
[Musik]
ich will einfach nur ein strand gehen
die kameras eingefangen heißeste tag in
deutschland gelten wetterbericht
geschaut in köln und uns gerade 38 grad
hier sind 28 das heißt aber 38 in köln
bietet der sand fühlt sich wie lava
sich schon darauf dass wir gleich einen
hund haben überhaupt schon gesagt heißt
max heißt der sechs monate alter kleiner
golden retriever bekommen meine zähne
statt der für sonnenbrand [ __ ] gern mal
wieder fachleute wir waren den ganzen
tag am strand haben gerade gewünscht
jetzt haben wir etwas abgeholt und zwar
den kleinen max email merckx kompass sie
was sie da eigentlich sollte da sitzen
machen dass sie jetzt auf jeden fall der
kleine maxi mit dem geben jetzt eine
hunde gassi das einzig und max das
franzose
[Musik]
jetzt bekommt max natürlich auch ein
kleine flecken maxi und weiter geht max
ist franzose habe ich ja gerade schon
gesagt also wir haben die die besitzer
haben wir kennen gelernt gestern in
einer bar und die wohnen in
südfrankreich und barntrup nur kurz mit
ich habe alles verloren gerade ach du
scheiße leute ich hab gerade alle
leckerlis verloren so richtig außer rand
und band
das war wieder richtig klar juli und ich
haben hund wirklich seit 20 minuten oder
seit zehn minuten das erste pass irrt
ist dass diese komplette tüte voll mit
bällen und leckerlis fallenlassen dieser
hohen komplett ausraste anfang ging es
auf jeden fall erstmal am strand mit
markt ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
gerade hier im sand das ist doch so
schön ich glaube hunde das ist so dass
der himmel auf aero hallo kleine hat ich
glaube dass der himmel auf erden denn
hunde am strand sind oder das ist so und
high score um buddeln und sowie kleine
kinder halt und setzt sich für eine
coole geworden hat sich da jetzt rein
gelegt heißt es so schön dass die sonne
das meer strand
[Musik]
kommt am 8 wir müssen mag es jetzt
leider wieder abgeben er ist auch total
erschöpft weil er ja noch mittelmeer
waren am strand und vor und hier geht es
aber erst mal das essen google gründung
freundin aufgegessen haben wir diese
freunde
es war ein sehr sehr ereignisreicher tag
ich hab zwar wieder nicht so viel
gefehlt weil es ja auch irgendwie urlaub
und wenn ich dann immer irgendwie eine
kamera dabei ist auch ein bisschen druck
doch ihr könnt das so ein bisschen
nachvollziehen
wir fahren allerdings morgen abend schon
wieder zurück nach köln morgen werde ich
ja eh nicht locken sondern der geblockt
doch war sie übermorgen mitglieder in
köln werden wieder spannende coole dinge
machen also hey weltfrieden für alle
roma carlisle auf weltfrieden
wenn euch dieser blog hier heute mit dem
golden retriever namens max gefallen hat
ein kurzer ausschnitt nicht wahr so sie
ist aber noch wie es letztendlich
gestorben oder so las einen like da
meine damen und herren wir sehen uns mal
machen in einem neuen blog wieder werden
noch nicht wieder zurück in köln sind
und bis dahin immer schön gemüse essen
aber auch ab und zu pizza lpc flecker
[Musik]